all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are
picking up with something besides the
x-men i feel like it's been a while
since we covered anything else in marvel
comics right we've done immortal hulk
we've done the x-men and i feel like
that's largely been it so
what i want to do here is i want to
cover iron man because we essentially
have the return
of what is one of the most powerful
cosmic entities in existence
kind of but not really you guys will see
what i'm talking about right it's
actually one of the coolest things ever
and i'm curious to see
if you guys can figure it out before i
tell you who it is so
this largely comes or really kind of
picks up with a bit of a conflict
between
iron man and terrax now tarax as a lot
of you guys know
is a long-standing villain in the
history of marvel comics he was at one
point a herald of galactus these days
he's small time right you don't really
see him being that big of a deal anymore
and even then when you saw him in
hickman's
avengers the new avengers run he was
really more of just a plot device
just kind of there for the sake of
telling a story and and so on and so
forth and
that's largely been his role in marvel
comics really since the 80s
but terrax is taken out quite readily
but one of the things that we end up
learning here
is that tony stark has left his own
company stark unlimited now this is
business as usual we've seen this happen
multiple times over the course of marvel
comics but the way that christopher
cantwell's doing this is really really
cool right christopher cantwell is a guy
who's currently writing iron man i was a
little on the fence when i heard he was
taking it over
i do not regret reading it his writing
is amazing he's really really cool with
this
but one of the things that happens is he
ends up getting a kind of 65 billion
dollar severance
package which is nice and then from
there like in his fight with terrax he
ends up like destroying a satellite
right and then of course he gets a whole
bunch of flack and a whole bunch of heat
on social media now one of the things
that any youtuber will tell you or
social media influencer will tell you is
take what people say on social media
with a grain of salt
social media is an answer to the
question what happens when people can
say what they want without consequences
and social media will basically show you
what people are really like right so
it's kind of interesting
at the end of the day tony stark seems
to kind of get caught up in a social
media to a degree but one of the things
that he's also kind of kind of
criticized for and grilled for a little
bit
is the idea of him changing his career
when he's like you know what i'm
stepping away from technology completely
machines should be building machines we
need to get back in touch with what it
means to be human and she's like when
you say get back in touch with your
roots
are you talking about this 65 billion
dollar exit package from stark unlimited
a 14.8 million dollar malibu mansion and
a computerized iron man suit
this is dangerous as a thermonuclear
weapon is that getting back to your
roots is that what you're referring to
because
if you're talking about becoming an
average man they don't have any of that
so it's kind of a funny little thing
there but social media largely seems to
have it out for him right you know it's
kind of kind of taking it to him but you
kind of get these little
tidbits here and there he kind of packs
everything up right he's kind of telling
roadie like pack everything up
right he's got his 1970 boss 429 mustang
which i always thought was kind of cool
but i'm more of a 1971 chevelle
450 big block man myself it's my dream
car
but it's kind of this thing where tony
stark's sort of just walking away from
it all right just literally leaving it
all behind and it's just like i want to
get back to a simpler life
and that kind of makes sense right i
mean it is very difficult to look at a
person who's a billionaire and see that
like you know man life must be a
struggle for them
but it's one of these things where a
person's struggles
aren't necessarily based on money
oftentimes they're just based on their
life experiences right the things they
go through and if you're somebody like
iron man you've never had a moment's
peace and you're kind of cursed with a
gift of knowledge to a degree but you're
always out there doing something right
you're always putting your life on the
line there's all these kind of threats
that go on time and time again
it makes sense that there comes a point
when you're like you know what i just
want to be done with it all right just
buy some brownstone and just live some
measure of a peaceful life and so tony
stark kind of starts to get a little bit
reckless or what you would expect a guy
like him to do if he's just sort of
getting out there and just
doing things that he always thought
would be fascinating like for example
getting involved in a street race now as
you guys know
from watching fast and the furious
nothing in this world is stronger than
family
not even galactus family can be galactus
family can beat
cosmic entities thanos would have been
defeated with the infinity stones and
the infinity gauntlet had family stepped
in but tony stark hiding involved in
these street races and so on he's just
kind of being reckless i mean to a
degree like he puts like five grand on
the line just to get involved in a race
with this guy
but while all this is happening small
little things are taking place right
small little moments are going on behind
the scenes
robberies break-ins and normally tony
stark would never really concern himself
with this but then we get the appearance
of a relatively interesting character
right he kind of tweets out that he's
holding a kind of a get-together with
some old friends and he ends up being
met with the arrival of patsy walker
hellcat now patsy walker
was a huge deal back in the day right
like back in the 70s and 80s she was a
huge deal and she's really been around
for a long long time in marvel but the
reality is she's just kind of been small
peanuts for a long time and that's one
of the things that i want you guys to
notice with what christopher cantwell's
doing here is
a lot of these old school small time
guys he's bringing him back
right he's bringing back a lot of these
old school small time characters and
it's kind of interesting because the
relationship between patsy walker and
iron man is such that they had a kind of
romantic interest at one point a bit of
a fling
but there's history there but in the
middle of them talking and having this
conversation
suddenly he's met by the arrival of a
guy named fuller tilehard i think that's
how you pronounce that's how i pronounce
it ortil hard whatever this guy
basically has this business proposition
now this is almost kind of a shot for
shot of iron man 3 when you had
when he had killian who approached tony
stark was like i had this really cool
idea you guys remember that whole scene
from iron man 3 i know you guys try to
block the movie out of your head but uh
this is kind of a shot-for-shot moment
of that when he basically pitches this
idea to him they could really change
everything right capturing lightning and
the whole idea behind that is
lightning is an exceedingly powerful
source of energy and it's naturally
occurring
so why not harness that and then
basically use like waste free energy
that can power the world right they can
do all kinds of things to fix the world
now
the reality is tony stark isn't
necessarily against this because he's
like i mean there's no real profit to be
made here or i can't weaponize it or
anything like that it's largely because
one he's wearing
fuzzy bunny slippers and two he just
doesn't really care about that kind of
stuff anymore it doesn't really seem to
be relevant to him anymore and so he's
like i mean lightning is cool you know
that's that's whatever and then just
kind of walks away with with patsy
walker you know this guy's kind of like
well let me know if you ever decide to
change your mind let me know
that will be incredibly important and
the reason why is because iron man
getting back to his roots is not
necessarily him
walking away from the role of iron man
and in fact he actually breaks out a
vintage suit from back in the day when
he was simply just the golden avenger
right an
old school iron man suit that in the
eyes of tony stark there's almost a kind
of level of humanity that's
lost with the advent of technology and
there's really no one better
to make that case than him right the
average person on twitter is not
equipped to make that case a futurist a
person who's developed some of the most
advanced technologies in the world
and in fact the foremost authority on
technology is equipped to make that
argument because he understands the full
breadth of what technology has done for
and to society and what it will lead to
that's one of the things to keep in mind
iron man's always been a futurist right
tony stark has always looked to the
future
he builds for tomorrow he doesn't build
for today and that's why technologically
even comparing him to people like reed
richards or like wakanda or something
like that he's usually always a step
ahead of them it's one of the things
that was established during
and at the end of jonathan hickman's
avengers new avengers run
is that in comparison to everybody else
out there t'challa
reed richards all these guys even peter
parker to a degree or even dr octopus
iron man's ahead of all of them right
just in terms of his ability to develop
technologies
the only thing that limits him is the
technology around him right what he can
build based on the existing resources
that he has
but if he were to go to wakanda and he
had all the resources in wakanda it
would dwarf
everything that wakanda's built already
i mean wakanda never really had the
ability to build a dyson sphere
tony stark did right you literally build
one around the sun it was one of the
most monumental achievements and he had
to use
alien technology in order to pull it off
it's one of these things where he kind
of sits down
and he has this bit of a conversation
with patsy walker and he starts out kind
of
kind of having this bit of an
existential crisis i don't really know
who i am anymore when she asks the
question like what's the whole point
behind this right what's the whole idea
behind leaving technology behind walking
away from stock unlimited and then
living more of a peaceful life and just
kind of going back to the days when it
was just
you and iron man and that was basically
it what's the point behind all this
right why are you even
hanging out with me like we haven't hung
out in forever and the response to tony
is i don't know who i am anymore right i
don't really know what my deal is
anymore i don't know my purpose in all
of this right an
existential crisis on behalf of tony
stark and that's when
in the middle of all this they suddenly
realize that unicorn is is launching a
heist
now you're probably asking your question
who's unicorn and rightfully so unicorn
hasn't been relevant in decades and when
i say decades i mean decades but you
know unicorn is a guy with super
strength right he can lift something
like 15 tons if my memory serves me
correctly he's pretty powerful right
he's a very easy he's a strong character
but he
is if there was something lower than a
z-list villain it would be him
but the crazy thing is the whole time
he's doing this he keeps referencing a
guy called the other
right and he's literally stolen this
book from a library of all places right
it's like why would this guy break into
a library
and steal a book but the other thing is
there's a bit of a few kind of
enhancements here
enough that he's able to really hold his
own against iron man kind of subdue him
for a second and then ultimately escape
but not before iron man basically you
know knocks down the helicopter sends a
crash into the ground and then basically
you know unicorn is arrested and iron
man realizes what he's stolen here
is the gutenberg bible now this is the
weirdest thing to steal because the
significance of the gutenberg bible is
it was the first book that was printed
with the gutenberg press which started
the process of just
mass producing books using machinery but
the fact that this is being stolen by
some guy like unicorn it doesn't make
any sense right it's like why like you
know
why would you do this and who's the
other right who's this being that you're
referring to and so what you end up
doing is you actually
switch over to this guy that that iron
man had been talking to previously
and this guy's just kind of standing in
a window staring out now if you look at
this bottom
panel here anybody who knows anything
about the history of marvel comics will
be able to tell you
right off the bat who this guy is right
if you ever read the history of marvel i
mean
if the artwork tells you who this guy is
but for those of you guys who are unsure
and those of you guys who have not been
able to
guess it yet you pick up one year prior
to all of this
and basically this this system is kind
of brought online right this being is
basically brought online by the enclave
now those of you guys who don't really
know what the enclave is
they are significant right they're
hugely significant the enclave were the
ones who basically developed adam
warlock the idea behind the enclave is
basically they're a collection of
scientists who want to run the world
right who want to like conquer the world
focusing on like science and technology
as opposed to having some kind of a
furious purpose right they're not really
looking to be like
you know dictators that rule the world
with an iron fist they just kind of
believe that humanity is its problem
and that forcing humanity to exist on a
more scientific and and technological
level
would basically make the world better
the other part of this is that this
guy's referred to as adam four
again kind of picking up from the adam
warlock project that adam warlock would
be referred to as adam one
and they've had various attempts over
the years to duplicate adam warlock
right kismet is a perfect example of
that but this guy says
do not call me adam call me by my real
name korvac
so this is kind of a crazy thing the
return of michael korvac and they asked
like what's your mission and it's like
something about saving the enclave i
don't know but your mission is selfish
right like and this is this is one of
the coolest things he says he says what
makes humans so
arrogant as to think their world is more
important than
any other why make the world a better
place why not make the universe a better
place a better reality for everybody
who's here and this guy responds and
says you're a cybernetic amalgamation
you're superior opinions on these
matters are beneath you it's your nearly
unlimited intellect that is required
and before he can finish he says it's my
nearly unlimited intellect that tells me
this universe is a landfill that is
conflict-laden and war-torn by the
greedy it tells me that this is a
reality that while filled with those
proclaiming to be gods
is ultimately godless and lost and
ultimately it tells me that i
am but mere steps away from becoming the
god that it needs
you can have your enclave i have bigger
plans and i must begin immediately now
this is the
bane of the existence when it comes to
the enclave when they originally made
adam warlock they had to fly in alicia
masters right the blind girlfriend of
ben grimm because the light emitting
from adam warlock was too bright for
them to see
and they had to know if their experiment
was a success but almost immediately
after adam warlock emerged
he turned against the enclave fought
alongside the fantastic four and then
bolted and then he kidnapped sif and
tried to marry her which is kind of
weird but it's the the bane of the
existence of the enclave that every
organism that they either manufacture
or alter ends up turning against them
because honestly
despite the the fact that they exist
based on the beliefs of science and
technology
they defy logic and reason in terms of
their motivation and why they want to do
what they do
and so switching back over to iron man
suddenly he's basically caught up in
murder world right now we don't really
know exactly how he got here and even
iron man says i don't know how i'm here
it's just him and crusher creole that
were snatched up and brought to this
place and crusher creel's like look if i
have to destroy you in order to get out
of here and that's exactly what i'll do
iron man ends up figuring out that it
was basically arcade and then of course
once they unmask arcade they end up
freeing themselves and so on but this is
going towards the kind of continued
crushing
of iron man as far as public opinion
goes that iron man is doing things that
the general public doesn't like and so
the general public
is turning against him whether it's
logical or reasonable is irrelevant
right that it doesn't really matter
whether or not what people believe is
logical and reasonable
it's just what they believe and people
will steadfast their beliefs and very
rarely ever change them unless they
absolutely have to and it's only really
in the face of conflict or destruction
that they have to change their opinions
but
you end up having this kind of situation
over and over and over again this is
what's happening
time and time again there's these
different villains that are showing up
here right one guy kidnaps a whole bunch
of guys from stark unlimited and tony
stark has to go in and save them you
know it's
just this kind of situation this kind of
process that repeats itself continually
that you end up having iron man who
basically kind of saves the day
albeit you know with a few dangers here
and there he breaks his bones right he
has like 17 fractures you know he's like
his left lung is punctured and so on and
so forth but like kind of enduring these
struggles over and over and over again
it's just kind of the nature of of the
current situation that iron man is in
because at the end of the day korvac has
some kind of plan under his belt and all
these these
guys that are being brought in is being
done for the purpose of serving this
plant now the question is why
because the next thing you see is iron
man who faces off against the melter and
the melter just like melts his car
and it's it's a weird thing right it's
almost like these guys are kind of
playing games with him screwing up his
head
you know just kind of appearing out of
nowhere it's just kind of small time
stuff you would normally never see iron
man
engage in a conflict like this with
these small time guys
but for some reason or another they're
all being brought together by korvac
for the purpose of facing off against
iron man unlike michael korvac
in you know as he originally appeared in
the sense that he was just basically a
lazy guy
right existing in a future that was
ruled by the badoon instead like he's
more or less been
kind of either recreated manufactured
whatever and is just kind of going off
his own schemes that makes sense to
himself and just
basically seeking godhood and that's
what he tells tony stark that ultimately
we find out that tony stark
backed the experiment of this guy not
knowing it was korvac
and in doing that this entire process
plays out the way
this guy intended it to where
essentially he kind of invites iron man
here iron man's like okay i want to see
what my investment bought me
and then as soon as that goes on he's
immediately hit by lightning right taken
out by this
by by quarterback and then kovac brings
together the other guys that have that
have more or less been freed right
unicorn's been freed the controllers
here but it's just kind of this thing
over and over where they're like we're
gonna take you out right i got these
three guys
because they seem to be the most
equipped in taking you on now this again
is another kind of reflection of the old
school quarterback stories
because the reality is these guys are
not a challenge for iron man and they
never really were
iron man was able to overcome them
pretty readily i mean guys like the
controller
are kind of powerful but they're all b
or c list villains and so it really
seems more of an indication that korvak
is kind of
learning as he goes along and that was
the nature of the original quarterback
once he stole the power of galactus and
was almost really more machine than man
even in the events leading up to that he
was kind of figuring things out as he
was doing them and that's why the
corvette saga is so cool
because you see this guy who's basically
lazy who's turned into a machine
who steals the power of galactus who
comes back to the modern day and then
basically just kind of becomes
more and more of a credible threat as
the story goes on all the way up into
the point where he reaches godhood and
that's what this guy is trying to do
that's why him and korvac are really
linked in this way is he's kind of like
seemingly a remade version or returned
version of quarterback because he says
i'm not looking to achieve demi-god
level status
i'll do that here in a moment right i'll
achieve this kind of demigod level of
power where i'm at right now
but i'm looking to attain full on
godhood that's his mission that's his
goal
because that's what the original michael
korvac did so with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end let me
know what you guys think down in the
comments section i love what's going on
with iron man right now uh and i will
catch you all later
peace